a disturbing trend in vegas the number
of murders across
town on the rise and the newest
statistics from metro show that domestic
violence is the number one cause so far
this year
orco mana explains what's being done to
address the issue in this special report
i thought it was going to be a good
relationship for courtney dillon what
was supposed to be a love story in 2017
took a terrifying turn three months into
it
i was physically hit and it only got
worse from there
her partner at the time abused her for
more than two years
i got a screwdriver thrown at my head
and
it started to bleed he stepped on my
hands very hard
stopped me with a fork on my back
and also on my hand because i was trying
to block it courtney tells me there were
times she did not think she would make
it
you're telling yourself you're going to
die you're going to
you're not going to live anymore the
latest numbers from metro police show
there have been 68 homicides in las
vegas through july 9th of 2021
in comparison there were 40 homicides
through that same time
last year that's a 70 percent increase
and the top factor leading to murders in
las vegas through july 9 of this
year is domestic violence at 12
homicides
this is real like this might be my last
moment when rachel haig was in high
school her boyfriend's verbal abuse
quickly turned physical
and she feared for her life he ended up
going backwards on the freeway
head on in traffic and was like this is
all your fault like we're both going to
die right now
rachel tells me what could have helped
is if there were more upfront resources
including in schools about domestic
violence maybe in the moment when they
are experiencing those things
things will click a little bit a little
bit quicker that kind of proactive
action is exactly what the shade tree is
trying to take the domestic violence
shelter provides housing and case
management for survivors
but now they're working on direct
outreach at local casinos businesses and
organizations
to get ahead of the issue whether we put
a booth up or you ask us to come
speak because awareness for us is very
important and it's key to bringing the
issue to
light they hope to start by this october
and survivors say that's a great idea
if someone would have came to talk to us
just all as a group saying like
you can come here you can have someone
to talk to it would have been
such a relief courtney is in a much
better place now but her healing
continues
i feel like i'm getting myself back but
i'm not totally
there yet orco mana 8 news now
those in need can call the national
domestic violence hotline at 1-800-799
the shade tree of course also has a 24 7
crisis line
you can find all of those numbers on our
website 8newsnow.com